hello my name is Bray Wyatt
I am the eater of worlds and if you're
not listening to bootleg keV and I
advise you run the party station who
like cam I'm very excited this is uh
actually actively Casilla pugs my
favorite wrestler of all time but
currently on the active rest wrestling
roster my favorite wrestler right now we
got Bray Wyatt in the building I love it
be a man brave Porter you are like it
extremely disrupt
it's been quite quite epic man like
congratulations on the last year it's
been about a year since you've really
been it's been a year I think the
anniversary was last week while I was in
Japan one year just terror yeah I mean
like you guys kind of took over where I
want to say kind of like where the
shield left off like this shield comes
as far as like causing a lot of terror
causing a lot of terror um what I mean
first of all let's talk about these
promos that you cut man like you are
these crazy prophetic just promos that
you have mastered man how long did it
take you to uh to master this like
character of Bray Wyatt I know you guys
are the next team for a while but yeah
that's that's what people ask me that a
lot and it's it's a really easy question
to answer because my ideals and my views
on society and the world and everything
around me and what I disagree with if
that we do as a culture the things that
we do as a culture it's all real so when
I go out there I'm not I don't sit back
here like some guys do and write a bunch
of stuff on paper right and memorize it
there's no one that hands me a script
and says read this because if they did I
throw it right out the window it's all
it all just comes from me you know it
flows out I go when I go and do these
these in
and these promos I go with the intention
of I have an idea of what I want to say
well a message I want to deliver and
while I'm out there it just it just
drains out of me man it just it just
flows out of me and it's it's a it's
it's it's real there's no there's
nothing there's no lies and no nothing I
made up I just I'm just giving you
myself and that's what they are man
that's great yeah and now you know
Harper and Rowan are kind of coming into
their own as a tag team so you guys kind
of got a nice little trio going on man
um can you talk about your days as Husky
Harris when you were coming up in Nexus
you know my kid spoiled it and he was
like yo white why was it WWE 12 and you
know a lot of a lot of wrestling fans
out there know you know like Ryback was
someone who who came who was part of
Nexus and came back is right back um how
did that kind of like help you cut your
teeth being understand opponent and
coming up through Nexus yeah when I look
when I look back at that era and I see
this character husky eras I just see it
sad little boy right you know it was it
was someone that was that was forced to
be something that he didn't want to be
and how he was handled it was it was
just a terrible terrible time a dark
period in in my life his life it wasn't
who I am it's not who I am today
and when I look when I look back at it
it's just I'm just disappointed in husky
eras right because it wasn't real man it
was a figment of someone else's
imagination that they tried to push on a
person I feel like it happens a lot of
times yeah like a lot of times in
wrestling like guys catch it like their
second gimmick around like the first
time sometimes it's not you know like
you said yeah the best the best I want
to use the word gimmick but the you know
it's a wrestling word that the ones that
work are the ones that really identified
with the actual person that's why you're
being yourself like I said no one could
tell you how to be you no one could ever
tell me how to be me but they did they
tried they tried real hard and and it
wasn't until I was thrusting through
than to that and I tasted failure that
it kind of opened something in me when I
went back to Florida and I came back to
Florida I was angry and frustrated and I
started becoming something else you know
I I don't know I don't attribute it to
growing up right something like that I
just I was so bitter and motivated at
the same time it's like like when you
hear of like like a rap artist you know
he takes everything that has has gone
against him in his life and everything
to put his back into music yeah yeah
everything to put his back up against
the wall and and his his outlet becomes
his music my Olympic game Wrestling and
it became talking and when I go out
there with a microphone I could tell you
about who I am and I get to tell you
about what I think's wrong with the
world and that's and that's the reality
of a man I never was husky Aricent
wasn't me right it was not a real person
right yeah Bray Wyatt is is Who I am and
it's it's what I want to portray it's
what I want to be remembered for and
that's who I am and that's great um
let's talk about sister Abigail I feel
like we are in like an era where so many
finishers are getting recycled just
because man let's be honest wrestling's
been around for however many years and I
mean it's hard to just pull stuff out of
your ass you know like new you know I
mean even like a guy like Roman reigns
his things the spear I mean how many
people about the spirit you done to me
sister Abigail was a very original move
the kiss on the forehead and just to
move itself yeah how did you come up
with that yourself or was that something
you had help with or well no no no one
else me no no okay
it's such a great great finisher how'd
you come up I think I think that through
the problem is that sometimes people let
people help him out too much and like I
was saying here man you got it you got
to be yourself right and the move I'm
sure the move has actually been done you
know as it's it's it's just a maneuver
but what I provided was a feeling the
actor it was immediate the bee
if you were so it's like when I pull
them out and not like when I dance with
them in the in the kids when I look him
in the eye and I say goodbye you know
I'm provoking a feeling and you a
feeling in them you know I'm trying to
get an emotional response and that's
what it does and that's why in my
opinion it's so special you know no one
done it nothing like I've done it you
know I agree ha ha ha what is it like
being a heel that I mean I always know
their skills that people genuinely just
don't like yeah like like the three men
been I don't know I mean of course it's
one man band round man but they're like
the bad people of keeping ninjas people
can't stand them like that but but you
like guys like yourself guys like Cesaro
like you guys are loved man like I feel
like there's more positivity towards you
guys than make it even like I mean you
know people probably do more for John
Cena the Wyatt family I mean I mean how
do you do you want people to boo like
cuz I mean at the end of the day you
know that's kind of your job as a bad
guy but you know at the same time you're
doing such a great job and cut and cut
across to the fan so easy so are people
not like the wife in well the way I look
at it is like on you when you put me in
John Cena face to face you would
automatically if you just saw us you
would go John's a good guy right braise
a bad guy but in my opinion every good
person does bad things and every bad
person does good things and what I'm
doing is I'm eliciting a response from
people I care about I believe in people
that's that's that's real me I believe
in people and as long as they're out
there and they're making noise and
they're excited when I come out because
when when I hear them react you and you
know you know when you hear someone
reacted for you it opens another door
inside you're self-conscious you know it
makes you want to give back to them okay
you came from me
to show you what I can give you and and
that's what it is if they were all
sitting on their hands and not making
noise I think then I wouldn't be doing
my job but boo share noise right you
know um I want to talk to you about one
of the most memorable moments in wrong
that I can really remember the last for
a long time this win Daniel Bryan joined
the Wyatt family yeah you guys got into
the cage and then you know he had his
moment where he took the thing off and
you know he betrayed Bray Wyatt and and
it was like one of those moments where I
was watching on TV and I had my
goosebumps like wow and way the crowd
was I got goosebumps when you just said
it yeah the way the cry got never seen a
crowd like that it was it was remarkable
what was it like being a part of that
and telling that story in the ring cos
you know storytelling in a ring is you
know to me probably the most poor Tina
Russell could be good at yeah and like I
said I got goosebumps just thinking
about it because know most people don't
know this book it was in Providence
Rhode Island and Providence is a
notoriously quiet crowd and on that
night they weren't quiet
they were riotous yeah you know and and
we ain't being in there and feeling that
moment every moment I had with Daniel
Bryan we had some real experiences
together possibly my greatest match was
at the Royal Rumble against him the
great match yeah and me and me and
Daniel Bryan are far from over
you know when he comes back and I know
we will we will probably go to war
hundreds more times you know and that
that I see him as one of my him and
Roman reigns and even John Cena I see
them as my greatest foes going forward
right 20 years from now they'll go wow
this moment happened with Daniel Bryan
and Bray Wyatt or Roman reigns and John
you know and that's that's what I'm
that's what I'm looking forward to I
need those guys yeah man you gotta have
those those like knows those Bret Hart
Shawn Michaels we look back and you get
it yeah yeah I said who's the guy that
like who's your favorite guy to wrestle
that you guys just get each other in the
ring
and you know it's fluid like who's if
you had to pick one guy to have a match
with - you know maybe headline a
pay-per-view who would be that guy that
you know you'd have just an amazing
match with me and dnad rose oh that's
great whatever is the order and you guys
are both kind of crazy yeah yeah me and
Dean Ambrose I wouldn't say they're the
smooth is probably my smoothest opponent
is Daniel Bryan but me and Dean Ambrose
when we were in Florida we used to do
this this florida championship wrestling
yeah yeah this was here Tampa yeah yeah
this is you know young I actually saw
something on uh assume somebody sent me
some picture one time and it was like do
I have I met it was the picture said
have I met you before and it was all our
early days from all the other promotions
us and the shield when we were all
younger faced off and there was a
picture of me and Ambrose doing the
bullrope match and we used to do that
everywhere you know we've don't know how
many times we fought but it's always
something
me and him have the special chemistry
where we can bring out something no
one's ever seen because like you said
we're both a little crazy and I think
that's like that's a few that's bound to
happen
oh there's no doubt among now that you
know now that the shield's the other so
abated you can throw out good guys and
bad guys and that 100% to two wild men